[Music]
archeologists in Peru have discovered
the nearly 500 year old skeleton of a
man who died in a surprisingly modern
way from a gunshot wound to the head a
team of experts believes the man is the
first documented victim of a shooting in
the New World the skeleton was uncovered
by a team of archaeologists headed by
Guillermo Kok a National Geographic
Society grantee who began excavating
this ancient Inca cemetery in 2004 the
Inca once ruled the entire Andes region
until they were conquered by the Spanish
in the 1530s the scientists realized the
cemetery was unusual when they found
bodies buried in unexpected ways because
evidence that they didn't follow the
period which they were without not the
proper offerings now the question is why
these individuals have been buried in
such an unusual way many of the bones
revealed fractures puncture wounds and
signs of violent death one skull stood
out marked with what appeared to be the
entrance wound on a musket ball what's
especially exceptional about this is not
only that we have in fact the entrance
wound but also that I recovered the plug
of bone that actually was in this
position on the inside of skull
to test their theory the team x-rayed
the skull searching for the metal
fragments a musket ball would leave
behind when the x-ray came up negative
the scientists turned to a more
sensitive tool a scanning electron
microscope hit paydirt
revealing bits of iron embedded in the
bone
it appeared that as the musket ball
punched into the back of the skull and
passed through the head
it left iron fragments deep inside the
bone which stayed there for some 500
years
Guillermo Kok believes the wound and the
hastily buried bodies in the cemetery
point to one conclusion the victim was
killed by a Spanish conquistador
wielding a primitive gun called an
arquebus the inca battled the spanish
outside Lima in 1536 near the site of
the graveyard believes that the
bodies buried there are the first-ever
forensic remains from the battles of
Spanish conquest